[Music]
from the hot girls summer to
truth-telling girl fall Megan nice
Italian is so not here for rumors you
wanna be near me 11 equally yea the
rapper is setting the record straight on
rumors that she's dating Tristan
Thompson
so first of all we're going back to
school okay so this all started after
Megan showed up at Monday's Cleveland
Cavaliers game fYI that's the team
Tristan plays for for some reason fans
were under the impression Tristan had
invited her to the game well Meg is
clearing that up on Twitter quote what
in the [ __ ] are you talking about and
lol they literally made up a whole lie I
was at the Knicks game with my manager
and my friend EJ and this one quote if I
ain't claiming him he ain't mine simple
and there you have it I'm just gonna
start going online cuz I ain't got time
no you play it with these people
plus it seems like Meg is focused 100%
on her music right now I'm busy every
day I'm literally on the move every day
some I don't even know what day it is
I'm good it's the hot girls summer
dating is it a dating summer I really
like you girl have a man you don't need
a man but you can have one if you choose
yes if he's worthy you know what I'm
saying
okay of your greatness if you're
allowing him to be a part of your self
allow you to sit with me yes I will
allow you to lay with me
[Music]
as for Tristan it seems like he's still
pining over Khloe Kardashian
following her big people's choice when
he posted this to Instagram writing in
part quote wow-wow-wow Khloe Kardashian
congrats mama Koko on winning best
reality star 2019 that's two years in a
row two-time champ I love the sound of
that so proud of all you have
accomplished this year I mean Tristan
let's be real you not being with Koko
anymore is all on you
just sayin but Khloe seems to be doing
a-okay on her own I really think I'm in
a good place but I think working on your
personal growth internally is something
that will be a forever mission and I
always want to evolve and grow and
mature emotionally because that's how we
become better people while the world is
changing around us we should adapt to
that too but always remember to be kind
and just courteous of what's happening
around you too alright guys that is it
for today for all the latest on your
favorite celebs keep it locked to all
things et until next time I'm Katie
Krause and bye for now
[Music]